good morning Hank it's Tuesday so after
my video last week a nerdfighter posted
this picture to Twitter with the caption
who wore it better Tom Hanks in castaway
or John Green in vlogbrothers also
someone in comments noted the PUF seems
to have migrated south for the winter so
yeah I trimmed my beard okay another
news Hank there's this line from my book
Paper Towns I'm in love with places I've
never been to and people I've never met
and that law has been quoted a lot over
the years I mean it pops up all the time
on tumblr it has over 1,700 likes on
Goodreads
now it's know if people were rain I was
drizzle and she was the hurricane it's
not even one of the most quoted lines
from Paper Towns but it's definitely
sort of widely out there in the world
there's even a poster available at
dftba.com designed by nerdfighter Riza
not to be totally honest with you I
don't remember writing the words I'm in
love with places I've never been to and
people I've never met but then again I
don't remember writing a lot of Paper
Towns that book came out seven years ago
sometimes I'd be on the set of the Paper
Towns movie and I'd be like why is this
happening and Jake Schreier the director
would be like because it's in the book
and I'd be like oh yeah right
how is the book anyway is it good I hear
there's a little bit too much Walt
Whitman so yeah when I started seeing
the quote a few years ago I just assumed
that it was in Paper Towns people kept
sourcing it as being from Paper Towns I
suppose instead of blindly assuming I'd
written something that the Internet said
I wrote I should have done some research
but you know Hank how many of us have
failed to fact-check something on the
internet most I would think flash
forward to last week when I come across
a post on the copyright subreddit and
it's like my friend wrote a thing on
tumblr that is now being attributed to
John Green in fact like they're selling
a poster of it and then at the end of
the post she was like you can just ctrl
F and search for that quote in Paper
Towns it is not there so I did I
illegally downloaded a pirated copy of
my own novel I had control f I searched
for the quote sure enough not there so I
get turns out I'm in love with places
I've never been to and people I've never
met was written by a thirteen-year-old
nerdfighter several years ago on her
tumblr she often quoted my books a lot
and made art using quotes and so someone
somewhere assumed that line was written
by me and then yeah now this poor young
nerdfighter melody gets lots of hateful
asks in her Tumblr inbox from people who
are like why are you stealing john
green's quote I stole the
I am the thief so I'm just to be clear
we've been selling a poster with a
quotation attributed to me that was in
fact written by a 13 year old
nerdfighter now obviously melody and
Risa are going to share the royalties
from that poster were retro actively
paying melodie for the posters we've
sold so far and also when I saw this
artwork of Melody's I was like I really
like that we should make that a poster
at dftba.com so now we have it's
available for pre-order all the
royalties go to me know they go to
melody now I admittedly I'm a bit of a
grapefruit for getting into this
situation in the first place like this
isn't the first time that a quotation
has been Mis attributed to me like
there's that line from the series finale
of the television program One Tree Hill
that has been attributed to me like
seven hundred thousand times on tumblr
by I did not write that but I think a
wrongly attributed author even a very
grapefruity one failing to notice the
misattribution in question speaks to how
screwed up credit and sourcing and
copyright are on the internet we do an
epically bad job of acknowledging one
another's work and checking our sources
so ink there's my story of how I came to
believe I'd written something I actually
hadn't hopefully we've gotten it right
now but I'm sure that somewhere
someone's copyright is still being
violated in all of this which reminds me
to tell you ain't it starting soon over
a crash course there will be an
introduction to intellectual property
and copyright law which is of great
interest to all of us who care about the
Internet and also like art and the
making of things you can check that out
soon at crash course and hopefully
together we can get better at this stuff
in the meantime please support Rize and
nerdfighter melody by getting their
posters Hank I will see you on Friday